باقتراب احتفالات النصر التي تصر موسكو
على اقامتها تنهال الضربات على الكرملين
صديقه هذه المره
مشهد اخر هز الروس بريجوجين الحليف الشقي
وامام جثث مقاتليه خاطب وزير الدفاع وقائد
الاركان بنبره غير معتاده
برفضهم اعطائنا الذخيره تسببوا في مقتل كل
هؤلاء الجنود سيحترقون في الجحيم تنقصنا
70% من الذخيره شويغو جيراسيموف اين
الذخيره
التي تحارب وحدها في باخموت وتتقدم حينما
يعجز الجميع تصرخ امام اخر كيلومتر يفصلها
عن تحرير المدينه الشبح ربما لان الانجاز
سيفقد الكثير من قيمته بعد ان فوت
احتفالات عيد النصر كنا في طريقنا لسيطره
على مدينه باخموت قبل التاسع من ايار
عندما راى البرقراطيون العسكريون ذلك
اوقفوا امدادات الذخيره وزاره الدفاع حسب
بريغوجين لم يعد يهمها نصر والانتكاسه
بقدر منع فاقنر من تحقيق اهدافها وحجته
التي تسلحت بلغه الارقام كشفت كيف ارسل
جيراسيموف عشرات الجنود فقط لدعم فاجنر
بدل الالاف تاركين رجال بريغوجين لوحدهم
امام الاوكرانيين الذين يفوقونهم عددا
بخمس مرات
هذه المره لم يكتفي بمهاجمه خصومه واتخذ
قرارا غير متوقع اما الذخيره كامله ومن
غير نقصان
او التراجع وترك مهمه بخموت للجيش الروسي
وحده صراع بريجوجين مع وزاره الدفاع بدا
يخرج عن السيطره رغم ان جذوره رافقت انشاء
الشركه التي استرجعت كل المغضوب عليهم في
الجيش الروسي والذين ظنت وزاره الدفاع
انها تخلصت منهم بمجرد اقالتهم ومن يومها
لم تتوقف الهجره نحو فاجنر
الجنرالو ميزنيتساف نائب وزير الدفاع
الروسي والمكلف بالامداد اقيل قبل اسبوع
واحد قبل ان ينضم الى فاجنر ويصبح نائبا
لقائد عملياتها ولم يبقى الان امام فاجنر
الا كسب دعم الروس لخوض معركه بقاء اخيره
داخل اسوار الكرملين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات